So I bought a new drawing tablets because I've been falling all these Instagram
artists and I thought it would make me a better drawer.
Well, apparently it didn't, unfortunately it's too late to return it.
So I might as well just use it to teach interview questions,
which is why I'm here. So what do my favorite interview questions?
Uh, I'm I'm kind of curious if you can solve it so ready. Okay.
You have a function called random that generates a number from
zero to one randomly, and it's uniformly distributed.
Now calculate the number PI. Now I really like this question because it,
it sounds so absurd in the beginning, right? It's almost as if, as, um,
it's almost similar to this question. Uh, Zoe has four apples.
Zoe gives one Apple to Tom,
and then she gives to Apple to Gary.
Now calculate the mass of the sun. Anyways, you can try to solve it, but, uh,
let's go to the drawing board. Oh. Sorry.
I think that's a wrong window. Um, it's it really nice looking Patrick though.
I wonder who drew it?
So the basic idea is to randomly drop points from a one to
one square or like a one-to-one grid since you can call the random function
twice.
And then what happens is that you get two numbers and then you'll use them one
for the x-axis and one for the y-axis. So for example,
if X becomes a 0.2 and Y becomes 0.6,
then where are you going to get is like maybe a point somewhere like here,
right? So why don't we draw a few more of these
now I'm going to give you a hint.
So I'm going to draw something and I think you will know how to do it now.
[Inaudible].
So, as you can see,
the goal here is to count all the points in the circle and count all the points
in the square.
The ratio between these two numbers will be pretty close to the ratio between
the total area of this circle and the total area of this square.
So how do you know if the point is in the circle or not? Well,
it's pretty simple.
You just take the distance between the point to the origin and if it's smaller
than one, then it's in the circle. For example, let's take this one. All right.
So that line, what is the distance? Well,
the distance it's basically X squared plus Y squared square root of that, right?
And then if that is smaller than one, then it's in the circle.
If it's bigger than one, then it's outside the circle,
but still inside the square. And then now it's just basic algebra, right?
So we all know that the area of a circle is PI R
squared, Oh, you know,
idiot. And then in this case,
the area of a square would be two times R and then
you square that.
And then with this ratio is going to be the same as the ratio
of the number of points in the circle.
So numb point circle divided
by the number of Toto points. So Toto.
So then now what we want to do is we just want to isolate PI.
So that's pretty easy because we know that R equals one here.
So this can be gone. This becomes two, two to two becomes four.
And then we just put the four to the other side.
So now it becomes PI equals four times the number of points in the
circle divided by the number of points total. Right. I don't want to write it.
So I'm just going to draw these booby looking things are these it's
color-coded so that's nice. And then if you want a good example,
so we could actually count them. Okay.
How many points do we have when we revise? I don't know, maybe eight,
eight points here. And then how many points do we have total?
Like maybe two more points here. Obviously I'm not counting,
but let's just say it's eight divided by 10.
So we get eight divided by 10 times four, I guess that's pie. Right.
And then, yeah. So that's pretty much it, uh, yeah,
coding should be pretty easy. So I'm not going to go over it actually, actually,
actually, actually I changed my mind. Um,
I think I am going to show you the code for it and, uh, yeah,
because I feel like I could explain it a little bit better while calling,
so let's do that. Okay.
All right. Cool. So we got our online rep here right now and uh, yeah,
let's just start coding it. So what we want to do is call it estimate PI,
and then I'm going to give it an N N meaning how many points do I actually want
to put in? So the more points, the more accurate, right. Okay, cool.
So then first I want to know how many points are in the circle.
We'll initialize to that to zero,
and then also how many points or in to Toto, meaning into square.
So then next,
what we have to do is just keep looping and keep adding these points.
So this means we're just looping and times. Um,
okay. Uh, let's see, is it, is it, this is it retinal,
but that's not it right? Hmm. Okay.
Let me check something. Okay.
Excellent. Okay. Uh,
Python random.
Okay, cool. Random uniform. God got it. All right.
So first I want to give my ex a number uniform from zero to
one same thing with my Y.
Zero.
To one, and then we want to calculate the distance.
So the distance what's X squared plus Y squared.
And then.
Yeah, we're just going to keep it at that.
We don't need two square root because what we care about is if the distance it's
smaller than one. So if you square root something, that's smaller than one,
one's going to be smaller than one.
If you square up something that's bigger than one,
it's going to be bigger than one. So who cares? All right. Circle.
So then if it is inside, like if it's smaller dent one,
then that means it's inside circle. So we add one and then no matter what,
we're just going to add it to the point to the total. Got it.
And in Indiana, I think that's pretty much it.
I remember when we did our algebra, we did the formula we saw what pie was.
So there you go. You just returned PI.
And in PI we remembered that it's four times the number of points
in the circle divided by the number of points in total.
Okay. Let's try this out.
Excellent.
All right. Um, estimate PI,
imagine if I just want 10 points in there. Uh. All right.
Random. Okay. Let's try this again.
Estimate PI. Excellent.
So 3.6, pretty close. I guess the more, uh,
points we put into our graph,
the more accurate it becomes that is not more accurate. Okay. Maybe a thousand.
Okay. There we go. 3.17 PI is actually 3.14,
so, okay. Oh, okay. Yeah, a little bit more accurate that,
let me check with PI is actually 3.1415. Okay.
Maybe a hundred thousand. Okay. Getting closer to 3.14.
And remember this is random.
So each time you press it or start each time you call it,
it's going to give you something different. So.
Okay.
[Inaudible] okay. Yeah. So let's try another one. Let's just add another zero.
Okay, cool. Yeah. Almost 3.1415.
It's probably not going to get that accurate. Let's just add one more zero.
I mean, it's not my computer anyway, so I'm not paying for the compute cost.
It is quite long.
Okay. Oh, wow. 3.1415, actually. That's pretty accurate. Yeah.
So there you go. That's what, uh, that's what it is and that's how you do it.
So, yeah. All right. Cool. And, uh, I hope that was helpful.
And back to the video, uh, yeah, coding is, should be pretty easy.
So I'm not going to go over it, uh,
of attaching to the description if you want to know. But yeah.
I feel like these tutorials check out quarter pro and also check out my new
educational channel, Joe macadamia. That's pretty much it. Peace.
[Inaudible].